F3: So this is really funny. This is another
example. Of controversy where there actually
isn't any controversy. Fox News ran an explosive
headline yesterday called Democratic Senator
Caught On Hot Mic explaining how Dems will fast
track infrastructure. What happened? What sort of
devious tactic or plan do Democrats have to get
infrastructure done? This is all about Democratic
Senator Ben Cardin. Ben Cardin was speaking
to Transportation Secretary Pete Butat Gedge
about Joe Biden's infrastructure plan and
Ben Cardin was caught. It was a hot mic,
guys. He had no idea he was being recorded. He was
saying Democrats will use budget reconciliation
to get infrastructure reform done, requiring
only a simple majority in the Senate
instead of 60 votes. Yea. Now, you might say,
hold on a second, Sir David. We've expected
Democrats to have to do that all along because
Republicans are and have been and will continue
to be total obstructionists there. There will
be no way to get infrastructure done without
using budget reconciliation. Why is this news
that Ben Cardin is saying this? And that is
exactly the right reaction, if that is your
reaction. Ben Cardin was caught. On a hot mic
saying something that we already knew and
expected in which Bernie Sanders actually
said publicly, here's the big explosive hot
mic moment. Take a listen to. I'm all ears.
I think it's going to be a job crosses
some parts of the world similar to help.
M9: Looks like we have.
F3: And
so there's Ben Cardin saying, hey, we're
going to have to do this like the covid
relief bill via budget reconciliation, where's
the scandal? Like, what choice do Democrats have
when Republicans won't vote for anything at all?
And in fact, Bernie Sanders, the funniest part is
you don't have to have a hot mic. Bernie said
this on February 24th. It's public record.
Axios reported on February 24th that, quote,
Senator Bernie Sanders told Axios on Tuesday
he's consulted with the White House about how to
prepare for the next round of spending. And he's
ready to do it immediately via reconciliation,
a process he controls as chair of the Senate
Budget Committee. There is no story here. OK,
Joe Biden said he wants to do infrastructure.
Got it. We desperately need to do infrastructure.
Spending on infrastructure spending is popular
with the American people. Good. Donald Trump also
promised to do infrastructure endlessly, and he
never did it. So it's overdue. And Fox News is
reporting as some kind of scandal what the obvious
publicly acknowledged strategy is going to
be on getting infrastructure spending done,
which Ben Cardin said to transportation, his
transportation secretary, Pete Boota, judge
that given Republicans plan to keep
obstructing, we are going to have to
do it via budget reconciliation. This scandal
is arguably less controversial even than when
Barack Obama wore a suit. And I would even go
as far as to say, and some of you may disagree,
this is less of a scandal than when Barack
Obama asked for brown mustard on a hamburger.
I'm actually willing to go out and say it is
it is less explosive even than that. So we've
talked about this. We did. We talked about this
yesterday. There's two different things going on.
Number one, Joe Biden is really boring. That's
true. And it's a welcome change in many ways.
The press briefings, aside from the sort
of weird questions from Fox News reporters,
the press briefings with Jen Psaki are boring
from a sort of salacious entertainment sense,
but they are substantive. And the right absolutely
hates this because there's just no scandals.
So they're manufacturing things. Ben Cardin
caught on a hot mic. Joe Biden hasn't done a
press conference for 55 days. I actually this
is even funnier this morning. Fox apparently
now that Joe Biden has announced
a press conference for next week.
Fox News had to up the ante, so this morning I
saw a graphic which was something like Joe Biden
hasn't done a press conference for eighty nine
days. If you include the twenty twenty campaign
before he was even president, Mr. Potato Head,
Kermit the Frog, Pepé Lapua, Speedy Gonzalez.
You know, all this this is what they are now
focused on because they don't know what to do
absent scandal, when the things that Joe Biden
has done so far, primarily at the top of the list,
the one point nine trillion dollar covid relief
bill are popular even with Republicans to a
great degree. I would expect more of this,
although my my prediction would be Fox News,
Max and on are sort of going to find their lanes
right now. They're kind of fumbling around in
the dark for like, what's the way we can get the
most clicks based on this administration? I think
they'll figure it out and they'll settle into
something probably within the next few months.